انا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد الياس حنا اهلا
بك ايضا حاله التاهب الجوي في عموم
اوكرانيا اعلنها الجيش الاوكراني قبل قليل
ما الذي يقتضيه ذلك عسكريا
مريم دائما دائما الهجمات الروسيه على كل
البنى التحتيه الاوكرانيه بدات منذ تفجير
جسر قرش نحن في عمليه استمراريه من هذا
النمط اليوم التوقيت والحديث المتكرر من
قبل القياده الاوكرانيه ان هناك هجوما
يحضر لهذا الموضوع فاذا اليوم هذه الانذار
على الصعيد العام هو
لخفض
الضرر على الناس وعلى البنى التحتيه وايضا
هو اذا بدك انذار للدفاعات الجويه وهنا
الاختبار الاكبر للدفاعات الجويه لماذا
لانه الدفاعات الجويه تدل ان الروس ان
الجيش الروسي جدد احتياطه من المسيرات
والا ما معنى الاستعمالها وجدد احتياطه من
الصواريخ والا ما معنى استعمالها قبيل
البدء والهدف دائما الروسي هو ضرب
الامكانيه الهجوم حتى قبل حدوثه
قال لكن العميد الملفت كما استمعت الى
مراسلنا قبل قليل هو استخدام هذا العدد
الكبير من المسيرات في كييف في حين ان
هنالك اتهامات للقوات الروسيه انها تستخدم
الفسفور في ماذا يعني بالنسبه لسير
المعارك لماذا تستخدم هذه الاستراتيجيه
الان روسيا
لكل هدف
السلاح المناسب له يعني
مركز القرار ومركز القياده يذكرنا
بالتهديد الروسي للقيادات الاوكرانيه بعد
مسيرات الكرملين اما في بخموت استعمال
الفوسفور هو
لتوفير الجهد البشري
الفوسفور عندما ينفجر
ويلامس الهواء يشتعل بدرجه 800 درجه مئويه
منهم من يقول ان هناك استعمال للقنابل
التفريغيه او التنمبرغ كما يقال وهي ايضا
مختلفه والهدف دائما هو انهاء ما تبقى من
مخمور 2.5% وبسرعه بعد ان تم التقارب بين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بين بريجوجين وحتى
قائد القوات الشيشانيه خديروف اذا اكثر من
معطى عسكري جديد يدخل اذا الى ساحه هذه
الحرب عميد الياس حنا هجوم مض تتحدث عنه
اوكرانيا وشبه جزيره القرم ايضا ساحه
مواجهه وجبهه مواجهه جديده اي منحه تاخذه
الحرب الان
مريم عندما تحدثنا في بدايه اللقاء عن
الاستنفار والانذار الجوي هذا امر يؤكد ان
لدى روسيه لا يزال السلاح الجوي سليم
سليما بالكامل هناك ما يقارب 900 طائره
حربيه اكثر من 200 طائره قاذفه ولا يمكن
اجراء او القيام باي عمل عسكري هجومي لانه
القوات ستكون معرضه دون الحمايه الجويه من
هنا هذا الانذار ومن هنا هذا
الاستعداد الروسي اخلاء اخلاء الناس
السكان من ذا فالوجيا وبالتالي القرم هي
القاعده العمق الاستراتيجي للقوات الروسيه
وهي مصدر اللوجستيه الاساسيه من هنا
استهدافها منذ فتره من قبل القياده او
القوات الاوكرانيه العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت
شكرا جزيلا لك